former Supreme Court Justice John Paul
Stevens is being remembered for his
towering judicial career Stevens among
the longest-serving justices in court
history died yesterday after
complications from a stroke he was 99
years old and served on the court for 35
years Jan Crawford reports on his legacy
on the bench John Paul Stevens was known
for his fierce independence
old-fashioned geniality and that
trademark bowtie he gradually
transformed from a moderate conservative
to a leading liberal voice I don't
really think I've changed I think there
have been a lot of changes in the court
I am confident that he will bring both
professional and personal qualities of
the highest order
President Gerald Ford 1975 appointed
Stevens to the court I will do
everything in my power to render the
best possible judicial service of which
I am capable he would go on to serve
under seven presidents his decisions in
part helped promote racial equality gay
rights and uphold legal abortions but
his biggest decision came in 2000 with
the court's decision to stop the Florida
presidential vote recount in Bush versus
Gore he told 60 minutes ten years later
it was one of the courts biggest
blunders I don't question the good faith
of the people on the the justices with
whom I disagreed but I think they were
profoundly wrong Stephens retired in
2010 he has stood as an impartial
guardian of the law in his retirement he
gave opinions from the sidelines calling
for repealing the Second Amendment and
abolishing the death penalty this is a
country in which people can disagree
without being disagreeable but try not
to be disagreeable in
opinion writing I think for the most
part I succeed
now Chief Justice John Roberts said in a
statement that Stevens his unrelenting
commitment to justice has left us a
better nation he's expected to be buried
in Arlington National Cemetery next to
his wife Mary Ann Gayle all right Thank
You Jan we all need more of that
disagree without being disagreeable with
us let's remember that